foreign
so this is for you and the first point
I'd like to make
is that there is a pattern
just we'll just use that word there is a
pattern
to the techniques
first let's go over some of the things
that we've said
there are three components three
concentric components to our training
okay we have
the spiritual
we have the energetic
did I spell that right
and then
we have the physical
when we say they're concentric we mean
as Is Happening Here Is Happening Here
Is Happening Here
also as when is happening here is when
is happening here is when is happening
here
it's not one leads to the other
so
in the energetic level
we'll take we'll take this one off for
now
it's just gonna complicate things
the physical the forms have a physical
component then they have an energetic
component and one is the other
so for example a physical aspect might
be Marshall
this
the energetic
pattern
is also the Marshall pattern
and the Marshall pattern is the
energetic pattern they're they're not
different and one doesn't lead to the
other so any
form
that you would look at and would say
that doesn't seem very Marshall you
would also see a violation of the
energetic pattern
okay
does that make sense to you guys
so for Aikido people who tend to go
it's not a martial art
and they say that now there's no
Marshall to it okay
if you if your art
if someone would look at it and go
you're right your Aikido is not Marshall
we would also see it's also not
energetically sound there's a violation
of the energetics there as well
so
knowing this let's look at the form
energetically we're going to look at
keyhonawaza energetically
energetically your form is going to have
in
Young
all this Ike
Earth
qi
water
poke you
haven't she
fire
D these are all
manifestations of the unknowable
unnamable
field of potentiality
what you're trying to do energetically
is reconcile these dualisms
to get back to the doubt
the way you reconcile these dualisms is
you start them rotating
kind of like you put in
a spice and another spice and you mix
them
do you see so they stop being too
so
your forms
will always adopt
this pattern
this mixing pattern
but this pattern has a micro
and a macro level
so
uke and I will be on a spiral
and we will be generating these aspects
and they will be generated by for
example
um centripetal energy
there's energy going into the spiral and
centrifugal energy there's energy coming
out of the Spiral
and I start mixing those things
right now
you can picture and again moving around
on a spiral
but the micro level is inside
inside my body
and inside Bukis body
so my
all of these forces
water fire they're moving inside
my lower tonden
this pattern is two-dimensional it's not
accurate okay
what you want to understand
is more
something like this
that is spinning
on its own Center Point
but is also traveling around that spiral
same thing in my body
so
this is a reference point
in my body
I'm going to start rotating
Yang Chi and yinchi
once internalized so I would rotate it
left or right it'll rotate
and then I'll lift it up so imagine that
this line is like this line
or over here
I move the line do you see
and I spin the line
then I rotate the line again
and then I come down
this is the internal pattern the micro
pattern
that spiral inside my body
mixing the yin and yang G okay so it
could start this way it could start this
way but after it starts that way it'll
go up it'll go the other way now and
then it'll go down
and that's what you're doing to ukia's
body as well so you start the technique
Luca is going to go right or left you're
both going to rotate around that pattern
is going to be brought up go back the
other way if they went right the first
time they're going to go left and then
they're going to go down okay
so if we have uh
does
is does both rotating cross patterns the
one to the right and the one to the left
that's that's what makes it a unique
training okay
so as I start
I rotate Pop I rotate it right it's
going to come around you're gonna see it
goes up you see
and uh I'm gonna do the other side of
the technique now whoa
around
top
and the spiral so I'm doing that inside
but watch our pattern our pattern is
spirally okay
so we start turning
turning turning
let me change it
[Music]
no spiraling pattern do you see that
let me add its headphones
no spiraling pattern
so macro
I use this spiral let's just look
two-dimensionally
and there's centripetal energy going in
their centrifugal energy going out
this is Yin
and this is generated by aiki
this is Young
and this is koku
in kaitenage
I he is applied to the Head
call Q is applied to the hip
but they are married with
those two Energies
centripetal
and
centrifugal
okay
that's what you're trying to do so
I'm going to generate an outwardness on
Uke's hip that's where I cook you
I'm going to generate an inwardness
that's where I hiking on Uke's head area
and then I don't have to do anything the
technique just does itself I'm in the
pattern so now I'm in
the doing of not doing I'm in
uh woo way
okay
now you'll watch for that so we're
coming around you you'll see a
centripetal
oh
okay
um let's do the second
uh poku one or the second kaita nage
where I came inside so I don't go here
stop him and then
I have to do another turn inside the
turn
so it's coming around
oh
around and around
do you guys see that okay so same thing
I use the two energy
oh
to generate what I need for him on
marshally okay as well so for example
going to the physical component
I'm in the Box
when I do this stuff I'm in the front
here's where he tackles me
stay in the back
[Music]
in the back
okay
let's try it ourselves either version go
keep going
okay so did you feel that did you did
you see that hiccup
okay so being here
good
oh
all right then you're going here like
this do you see that yes so I gotta pull
you
this step goes with the head
in
okay
so when you when you measure here you
came this way then you had to wait for
them to get there and now you're just
using centrifugal energy you're just
pushing out
so as we're making the spiral
you have to make a spiral at your
extremities
so your head goes one way
and your hips go another way in this
technique okay
so we're coming around
go off
okay and that's without the hip you see
okay
this is the hip without the head do you
see that yes okay so do one without the
hip okay and one without the head
there you go so with the pattern I'm
generating centripetal and centrifugal
energy
those energies are what I
um
manipulates
to generate Coq and icing okay so uh as
I come around it's because he wants to
go out you see that there's an energy
going out and I match that on the icon
hand
so let's say that was the value of x
then I drew a value of x and then we get
stuck okay do you understand that but
it's his outward generating energy that
I use to adhere at that point it's not
that I grab his head okay
so uh we're going on whoa he's going out
and this is what I and stuff on you you
got that don't grab the Hat
and then
once so he's going out
and once I get the end here
that energy is what starts the Coq
energy because that inward energy is
what I bounced
off of this hand
okay so it's not I'm not going like this
and pushing
because he's spinning inside a spiral I
can adhere boom and project on the hip
okay so that's our 10 feet wow
yeah do you guys see that okay
foreign
so notice how it's going where your head
hand is going yeah okay
it's not it's not supposed to okay so
come in here and here is your here's
your head hand right so you would you
have centrifugal energy right so you
have centrifugal energy and that's what
I use there you see then you're going
out
okay
going like that you can see that okay I
want to spin you and we're going to do
the rotating cross inside the spiral
okay remember how I said that it's not
it's not a two-dimensional thing okay
so we go around
boom
ah here
see how that goes on your hair yes okay
do you feel the projection yes okay so
the eye key
is benefiting and continuing the
centripetal energy I ground that boom
and I hit the hip and that's what causes
it
do you understand it as opposed to
[Music]
I just go around this way
you didn't
okay here we go
so therefore the you can do incorrect
kihon Wasa they'll be marshally
inviable and also energetically
contradictory
okay so like you don't you don't have
these versions like this
you don't do those verses
you can you can change as you see one
little then intern
oh the same thing not like this do you
see that
that's not going to be you're not going
to have the spirals going okay so you
can boom there's a spiral
this ever so slightly boom there's your
spiral
oh
you see that you guys see that okay and
inside I'm doing that inside I'm doing
that which is what's most important okay
that's the energetic level but Marshall
Lee
look I stay here he has total violence
until I go to here there's no way that's
going to work
but you clear the line you already get
the Tilt going you see
what's good
okay but inside I'm doing it too which
is most important okay
um so same thing
not here like this
[Music]
we we have to turn spiral oh
have to do it at least on one side
but keep no nagada does both sides
inside
okay
um let me say this the uke never stops
did you notice that the UK never stops
because
the spirally rotating cross never stops
so the UK should never stop
so I should never have him
stop
stopped then go stop no
the uke is always moving oh
always moving on whatever the version
doesn't matter
never stops because the key the chi has
to always keep moving
that because I'm spinning them
do you see
hey